so we've been looking at the geometry of
complex numbers
when we started to realize that you
could take every complex number and
represent it
as a point on the complex plane we
started to realize that you could form
shapes out of these complex numbers
especially when they interact with each
other and this is really helpful for us
human beings are visual creatures and
because mathematics is a lot about
perceiving
patterns if you can see those patterns
in a very
literal way then it helps you identify
and understand
what's going on so we're going to have a
look at this series of questions and see
what kinds of geometric
insights we can gain about the
arithmetic
of complex numbers so let's let's dive
in they give us a pair of complex
numbers
z here which is 3 plus i and w which is
1
plus 2i so the first thing i want us to
do is to plot the points
representing these complex numbers onto
some argan diagrams and i've got a
couple of the particular questions
sub questions from this one picked out
for us to do
so for starters we need to get z and w
themselves you can see these are the two
things being requested
onto our argan diagram and it's really
important that we always mention
we are not talking about an x and a y
axis as two real
numbers we're talking about a real
number which we represent as um
as our x-coordinate if you like and then
an imaginary number which we represent
as our our y or our vertical coordinate
so therefore we can think of we can
conceptualize a number like three plus i
where does it live it lives at three
comma
one that's the real and the imaginary
components
and then conversely a thing like a w
would live
at one comma 2. so let's go ahead
and plot both of those on there i'm
using a grid here but obviously if you
just have
lined paper it is really helpful if you
get a set of consistent
scale so i'm going to have my w sorry my
z rather
over here i'm going to label that
accordingly z equals
3 plus i and then i'm going to grab my w
at 1 plus 2i
so there are the points that are
represented now in this particular part
of this question it asks us to focus on
the conjugates so
z bar and w bar which you can see here
and here
now before i reach for the actual point
where they belong i want to make sure i
understand
what is the conjugate right well for z
being
three plus i its conjugate will be the
same real part
but the opposite imaginary part three
minus i so where is that going to live
well it's going to share the same
horizontal coordinate so you can see
it's going to be in line with wherever
we
plotted z but it's going to be well
minus i where is that
it's going to be down here this is z bar
okay
so that's that point we'll come back to
its geometric significance in a second
let's put w bar on
as well so being that w is 1 plus 2i
w bar is 1 minus 2i
so i'm going to put or place w bar
down here so hopefully you can see here
when the question then says
describe any geometry you observe
there's a relationship between z and z
bar
that is the same as between w and w bar
every time you take the conjugate the
same thing is going
on because you have that same
x coordinate the same horizontal
coordinate that's why we notice that
z and z bar and w w bar are vertically
in line with each other so you can see
that sort of connection in here
for z and then in here oopsie daisy
wrong one
in here for w
so it's good that we can see that
connection but more than that there is
also
this connection of distance right if you
think about where the real axis
is we're actually getting a reflection a
mirroring down
in this case from the positive side
above the real axis down
beneath obviously you can see that
there's this distance here
which is one and this distance is
matching it with one but it's in the
opposite direction
same deal over here this distance is two
and
so is this one so i guess the way we
would articulate this
is if we're trying to describe the
geometry we're observing the conjugate
is a reflection
of that original complex number across
the real axis so you end up getting this
vertical effect here
now this idea of reflection is actually
not new perhaps you just haven't thought
about it that much
when we think about regular conjugates
you know we thought about conjugates
before we thought about
uh complex numbers if i said to you oh
i've got a number like say
well how about a 3 plus
root 2 and 3 minus
root 2. so these two numbers we would
have called conjugates
there is the same reflection idea on the
real number line it's just
slightly different if we just plot a
real number line i'm just going to grab
this one
just pinch it put it over here let's
make it a different
color just so we can distinguish it so
excuse me
if we imagine this as just our real
number line on its own and if i place
you know
let's put 0 somewhere over here and that
would place
if i count along one two and then three
so we'll place
three there you're actually going to get
both of these conjugates on
either side of three root two is about
one point
four so if i were to place 3 plus root 2
i imagine it would be on the scale i've
used somewhere around
there that would be 3 plus root 2
and then 3 minus root 2 is going to be
on the other side
i guess 3 take away 1.4 ish is about 1.6
so that's why you're going to be
picturing it somewhere around there
3 minus root 2. so you can see there is
this same idea of reflection it's just
in a different
fashion you've got this kind of you know
vertical
axis in here if you like around x equals
three
and then you go to one side to get one
conjugate and you go to the other side
to get the other
conjugate so reflection is kind of at
the core of what the conjugate means
but because we're on the complex plane
over here you can see it's not
a real reflection it's it's a reflection
in the
imaginary direction across the real axis
okay great so we've got z w and their
conjugates there
i want to see what happens when we start
to put some operations on this some
arithmetic
as well so the next set of questions or
some parts underneath this that i want
to highlight
uh when you add these numbers and then
when you do some of the subtraction
operations so i already have z and w in
place let's see what happens
when we do the addition now we've begun
to explore this
already but i want to kind of make the
geometry very explicit
so z plus w because z is
3 plus i and
w is 1 plus 2i
just crunching the numbers excuse me
collecting like terms
for the real part and then the imaginary
part we're going to get 4
plus 3i so we can go ahead and we can
plot that
where's that going to belong well i see
it about there
that's z plus w and so just to sort of
confirm what we were looking at before
if we think of z and w as kind of like
a set of instructions for where you need
to go go
you know for z go three to the right and
one up you end up
at this spot over here right in fact i
might even put both of those
instructions
separately for you so here comes the
three
to the right and here's the one upwards
and then we have a similar kind of set
of instructions always a real part and
imaginary part for w so
you go one unit to the right and then
two units
upward for w so you can see let's move
this
letter z out of the way over there we'll
do
if i do z and then i do w
there's that operation there which
represents w you can see that's why we
get
to z plus w up there in the top right
hand corner
okay now this is going to start to get
busy but i think we'll be able to fit it
in there
let's do z take away w as well so
z take away w where's that going to land
us
well it's the same operation that we saw
before the same order anyway
but i'm subtracting instead of adding
so if i change that there we go
collect our real and imaginary parts
again so 3 take away 1 gives us 2
and then i take away 2i gives me
minus i so where is that going to go
2 minus i is going to be here so this
will be
z take away w now how do we fit this
together without understanding well
if you think about what w asks you to do
it is go to the right one
and then go upward too so this is doing
the opposite of that what we're adding
is negative w so if you want to think
about it this way
you're kind of going 1 unit to the left
and then
2 units down that's the actual operation
that we're doing so you can see that's
what lands you
i can i can do it here one unit to the
left
and then two units down you can see
you're sort of going in this bit of
spiral action here right
maybe if you want to think about this in
terms of triangles it's going to become
a little easier to conceptualize because
there just won't be many as many lines
flying around if i think about what's
happening
in these terms i've got w coming up that
way
i've got z going this way so when you do
z and then w consecutively that's what
gets you to z plus w
when i think about z minus w you're
going in this opposite direction
after you do z you do negative w and
that's what lands you
over here now to finish we notice that
you can do z plus w or you can do w plus
z
if you if you start from doing the w
first and then you
follow that with plus z you end up at
the same point and that's because
addition
is commutative but subtraction is not so
if we go ahead and change the order here
if we say w take away z what we're going
to do is we're literally going to switch
these guys around
so i might do it like so
i might as well just write that minus
sign you can see of course
as we're used to you're going to get a
different result maybe you're
anticipating there's a faster way to do
this than just to actually do
the number crunching i'm going to get
negative 2 from 1 take away 3
and then i'm going to get plus i from 2i
plus sorry 2i minus i so you can see
this result here w take away z
of course we shouldn't be that surprised
it is the exact opposite it's the
negative version
of the subtraction that we carried out
before so where is that going to land us
let's use another color over here i'm
going to say there's
minus 2 plus i so there is w
take away z and you can see why we end
up in a different place
if you're doing w take away z you start
with
this w and then the second operation
is negative z right so therefore or
you're adding negative z
i should say so that's why you end up
going in this
direction so when you do the subtraction
in different orders
here was the first one z take away w
and then here let's choose a color blue
i haven't used that here's
w take away z so that's why of course
you end up
at different places but as we've noticed
they are on opposite sides
of the origin so you can see there is
that visual connection as well
so you can see i'm starting to
understand all of these shapes seeing
the parallelograms
uh the triangles that are inherent to
doing complex arithmetic
will really help you to gain a sense of
what is all this number crunching
meaning
and it's the same deal with
multiplication division as well and when
we get there
spoilers things like say square roots to
think visually about what that means
will be really interesting will help you
gain insight